good morning Hank it's Friday I'm in a
hotel in Milwaukee because the yetis
cousin is becoming a Catholic priest and
I am here to witness it today's video
comes to you in 12 parts that's right
Hank 12 parts I think that might be a
parts record hold on a second sorry Hank
the 2010 FIFA World Cup has just begun
and I am an interesting fact about me
Hank is that I have watched at least
part of every World Cup game since 1994
part one gotta kick it kick it off oh
thank South Africa just hit the post in
the 89th minute part two as far as
Viacom stealing my video goes I still
want my money as far as I can tell what
Viacom did to me and what they've done
to hundreds of others is the exact same
as what they're suing YouTube for
purportedly doing to them Hank we talked
to some lawyers who think that Viacom
probably made whereabouts of $2 for
stealing my video if Viacom is so
opposed to piracy I assume they'll be
sending me my two dollars soon part 3
part 4 so Hank VidCon is less than a
month away in a related story oh is the
sound that my anxiety makes there's no
more rooms at the hotel available but we
got a group rate at a different hotel
the prices are about to go up for VidCon
for the last time plus it's almost sold
out so nerdfighters do you want to go
you should probably register now it's
gonna be fun in addition to all the
youtubers lots people from YouTube are
gonna be there we're gonna give like key
notes about the inner workings of
YouTube which will be fascinating to me
is there anything else I supposed to say
if you're under 18 you will need someone
in your party over 18 in order to check
into the hotel sorry oh and Natalie Tran
can't come communitychannel she's so
great but she can't come all the way
from Australia we're bummed out about it
but we totally understand part 5 what I
love about soccer is that rewards the
perfect balance between creativity and
discipline in which sense it is exactly
like writing books only it's so much
more beautiful than writing books which
is why I am not working today
part six I'm so good at counting oh if
only it weren't for Tyrion Ruiz hands
part seven I get so nervous have to
watch it on mute part eight Ming master
Tom I keep forgetting to say this Hank
because last time King master Tom
appeared in a video he was comatose but
Ning master tom is fine he's got some
problems with his left eye but he's
doing much better he is very grateful to
all the nerdfighters for your support
thank you guys for being so awesome and
for helping him in his recovery part 9
I don't even care about this game why am
I so excited part 10 oh great save part
I don't have enough fingers Oh
and lastly part 12 I have a new website
John Green books calm at which you can
find out about forthcoming nerdfighter
gatherings and other events in like
Washington DC and Munich Germany and
Edinburgh Scotland and London England
incidentally Paper Towns just published
in the United Kingdom please buy it
otherwise they will never publish
another one of my books there alright
Hank I have to go watch France play
Uruguay but I'll see you on Monday